they're kind of the stand-up comedians
of criminals right the serial killers
they are the stand-up comedians they're
they're kind of they're unrecognized
they kind of they work their way up they
work alone
right they serial killers rather I mean
outside of the Nazis they they don't
really work in groups they're usually so
low they they often you know like if
they're you know Ted Bundy he traveled
he would go on tour the best ones you
don't really know their names right the
hacks usually you know like they're
always trying to like tease the police
so they get their name out they're like
you know who's the hack was that BTK
killer right because he named himself
and then he was trying to get all his
attention